hi this is Dr Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason I O
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught Philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts
sometimes it's the way things are said
or how the text is structured
but the concepts themselves are not
always that complicated and that's where
I come in
to help students and lifelong Learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to YouTube many
viewers say they find them useful
what you're currently watching is part
of a new series of shorter videos each
of them focused on One Core concept from
an important philosophical text I hope
you find it useful as well
in his short work on controlling anger
Plutarch is going to caution us against
misidentifying our anger as a different
kind of emotion or we could say
affective comportment which it resembles
in significant uh traits and and details
but is different from in a number of
other ways and it's often translated as
righteous indignation
literally
miso poneria misos is hate and then
poneria wickedness right so hatred of
wickedness righteous indignation works
for it quite well because it's a feeling
that we direct towards those who we see
as wrongdoers now we can get angry as
well at those who are doing wrong
especially when they've done wrong to us
but righteous indignation nation is you
could say a little bit less focused on
ourselves and the people that we
identify with or are concerned for or
care about and it's more General it's
you know seeing wickedness and then
disliking that you know having an
attitude of disapproval and perhaps
hostility in uh there's another term in
Greek that Aristotle uses Nemesis the
word that we actually do get our nemesis
from which is covering a similar ground
this one actually makes it much more
clear that it is about hatred of
wickedness or Badness anger is
Plutarch uses these pretty synonymously
in this and he tells us that all too
many people including ourselves and you
know the person who's narrating at this
point tend to excuse their anger by
calling it righteous indignation so if
you if you are angry and somebody calls
you on it then you can say oh you know
anger is bad but righteous indignation
is actually good and just and deserved
and that's what I'm feeling I'm not
angry at these people as such I'm
feeling a hatred for the Badness that
they are presenting and he says um
you know this is not particularly
effective with the other passions and
even diseases of the Soul he says that
we can't rid ourselves of these by
calling one foresight or another one uh
generosity and another one piety they
are what they are right and we can call
them all sorts of things but it doesn't
actually make it so and then he goes on
to talk about some ways in which anger
is actually different from righteous
indignation you can say that righteous
indignation is in some respects a less
complicated more pure emotion and he's
got this very interesting metaphor of
seeds he says that Zeno the great stoic
right used to say that the seed was a
mixture and compound drawn from all the
faculties of the Soul so anger or temper
thumos in this case appears to be a
mixture of seeds drawn from all of the
passions tone python
Ponce
right so panspermia means so spermosis
is seed and so upon all so it's a
mixture of all these different emotions
obviously anger doesn't actually involve
every single emotion of the Soul all
Plutarch is being a little bit
hyperbolic here but it does have as he
identifies
seeds or origins in a whole bunch of
passions or emotions he says it is drawn
from Pain and pleasure Lupe and Hayden
right and then he said something really
interesting
hubris is one of the seeds of anger
hubris can be translated as it is uh and
this one is insolence or insult it's a
desire to injure or humiliate others in
order to get something out of it for
oneself to place oneself above others
Aristotle actually identifies hubris as
one of the three kinds of sliding that
is a cause of anger and that kind of
stuck in ancient times but it doesn't
have to be necessarily the other
person's hubris if the seeds are within
us then it's also our own hubris our own
tendency to place ourselves above others
and to sometimes you know desire their
harm and then he talks about Envy as
well and he says that Envy is also
involved in uh anger in some way says
although anger has envies malicious joy
in the ills of others so Epi hayrikakian
right which is what mesopeneria could be
uh against right malice is another way
we sometimes translate this literally it
is setting one's hand to doing evil
right so although Envy has this uh sort
of
whatever we want to call it
um
Plutarch actually says that anger is
worse than Envy
so this is you know quite interesting
um so you know anger involves all these
things
um
mesopeneria righteous indignation not
quite so much
then he talks a little bit later about
how it is that righteous indignation can
lead to our being
overcome with anger what is uh what is
involved in that he says those of whom
it is true that righteous indignation
causes them frequently to be overwhelmed
by anger so you know we we see people
doing bad stuff we if we read between
the lines we kind of personalize it now
we're angry at them not just feeling
righteous indignation and so if that's
the case for us you know we're reading
the paper or Twitter or pick whatever
all you're seeing something on TV or
down the street and we're like oh I
don't like that those those bastards
they shouldn't get away with it
well we can do some things about that
one of them is to as he says get rid of
anger's excessive uh form right so we
can we can keep the anger that we do
feel within certain limits and then the
more interesting suggestion right here
that he's going to spell out in in
detail is that like he says we we get
rid of extreme confidence with those
whom with we live and what is that so
it's
day right so pistis is translated
sometimes as Faith or Fidelity but it
can also be translated as confidence in
the sense of being confident in somebody
you know trusting in them Trust might be
another way of talking about it we
shouldn't reveal too much of ourselves
to others and we shouldn't have others
taking us into their confidence uh too
much and who is this with uh ton soon
those with whom we uh you know we could
say we live we exist so the people with
whom we're involved with obviously you
do want to have you know some deep
confidences say between spouses or
friends or family members but that
doesn't mean that you have to let
everybody in on everything you want to
avoid as we call it today over sharing
and he says this kind of confidence more
than any other cause
increases the anger when for example one
who has been accounted honorable proves
to be not honorable proves to be base
instead vicious right or one who we
supposed a true friend finds fault and
quarrels with us and the narrator says
as for my own temperament you know how
strong are the impulses which incline it
to be of Good Will towards my fellow men
and to trust them consequently like men
who attempt to walk on empty air the
more I give myself up to loving a person
the more I go astray and when I Stumble
and fall the greater my distress so the
best thing to do is to avoid excessive
trust or confidence in other people so
that when they they let us down or
reveal to us a different side we're not
completely deranged by it feeling either
anger or righteous indignation
the last thing that he says in relation
to righteous indignation is uh that we
can look at our own examples right
he says that when we see people doing
things wrong not only can we say oh well
you know they're they're not perfect
people we can also look at ourself he
says if we keep repeating to ourselves
Plato's question
can it be that I'm like that
could I also have the trait or fault or
whatever it is that I am so angry about
in other people the thing that I'm
seeing as wickedness and then becoming
angry over he says if we turn our reason
inward towards our own self right and
not just to external things and we
substitute caution uh
Ula Baya this is a very important term
this means a sort of rationally felt
fear or concern about things that really
do matter right if we turn if we
substitute caution for being critical or
sensurious then we can observe uh that
we're not going to make such use right
so this is an important term this is a
word that we do translate is use or
dealing with we're not going to take the
feeling that we have and direct it in
the way that we do we're not going to
use righteous indignation in that way to
be hurting others to be taking revenge
on others and he says that why not
because we'll observe that we ourselves
stand in need of much Indulgence much
people making you know not necessarily
excuses but giving us some leeway giving
us as we say the benefit of the doubt
and he says that uh you know when when
we're angry at inflicting punishment we
say don't steal don't lie why are you so
lazy
but we ourselves do that to others and
we should think about what it is direct
reason inward about our own lifestyle
and consider whether we're guilty of the
same false and he notes something that
is very interesting here as well kind of
on a meta level or a reflexive
reflexivity of a angry says what is most
disgraceful
in Greek of all is that we when we're
angry so we're already angry we
criticize others for being angry and we
punish by rage faults that other people
have committed in a rage so we're being
sort of like doubly hypocritical if
we're saying you're not supposed to be
angry and do dumb stuff and then we get
angry at them and want to punish them
for the dumb stuff stuff that they did
we're doing an additional dumb thing
right we're adding to the whole content
you could say of dumb stuff or we're
putting a bow of dumbness on the
presence of dumbness if you want to draw
out this metaphor so there's a lot of
things that Plutarch has to say about
the distinction between anger and
righteous indignation and how we
shouldn't allow our you know tendency to
sugarcoat our own failings and to ignore
them to lead us into thinking that
righteous indignation is what we're
feeling when we're really acting on
anger itself which is not good for us or
for others